[Music]
now obviously I want to start with you
posing with your beautiful daughter
first on the red carpet or the lack
thereof
and she's gonna be 18 in a couple days I
mean can you believe it um no I'm in
shock they alternate between like crying
and feeling really proud of the woman
she's become it's really fun and I'm
watching her watch you and there's no
question how proud she is watching you
through all of this it's me she's my
best friend and we do everything
together it's gonna be hard for her to
leave I seem to be handling everything
really well ET spoke with the 41 year
old actress on the red carpet at the
premiere of her new film home again
where she also teased her upcoming
appearance on longtime friend Mindy
Kaling's final season of the Mindy
project I did a little cameo I don't see
what happens and it was really funny
Mindy's a great dear friend of mine for
many years so I was happy to be there in
her last season pregnant there's gonna
be a moment
[Music]
you